hello youtuber verse Startalk coming up
next cosmic queries the edge of the
known universe this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist today we're
doing cosmic queries topic the edge of
space-time the edge of the universe
Chuck hey now you're gonna join me there
I am but we can't do it alone that shirt
you know you know whether you're
watching or listening that I wear
cosmically colorful clothes yes but my
shirt I'm wearing today is particularly
cosmically colorful yes it's in your
face its smackdown it's it's well we're
gonna have to yeah you're gonna have to
go to youtube we'll take a picture of it
and you have to see this shirt you have
to yeah seriously it's pretty lovely
celestial bodies getting on there we
have Jan 11 2014 10 so what do you have
so we got cosmic queries as well as we
glean from all over the Internet and of
course we always start with the patreon
patron because I'm just a quick check
you did so your book black hole blues
yeah it says every time you walk past it
on the Shelf all you just heard
so that was about the discovery of
gravitational waves yes moving through
the universe yeah exactly so right right
before that succeeded in the fifty years
it took this well we successfully
measured it yeah ray Weiss was mighty
original architects just was shaking his
head and saying you know we don't detect
black holes this thing as a failure so
like the whole title was kind of like
it's the black hole blue Nobel Prize jig
he said all the way to the bank on that
one yeah yes thank you for that let's
start off our though with a patreon
patron uh this is Chris Hampton who
supports us on patreon who wants to know
this could it be that the universe that
we are in is actually finite however the
universal structure is infinite via size
and relatively meaning the universal
structure gets infinitely smaller and
vice-versa
kind of like infinitely dividing in half
I imagine it would look something like a
very complex fractal question for Chris
first is it sativa ended which is the
one that he would have fallen asleep
before making it to the end of the tweet
[Applause]
when I actually use that it was called
we didn't put any other name
like if you would easy to pronounce and
remember that was it right if you went
to your dealer and you win some a sativa
anyway so you want to take a shot at
this okay so my first book is about
whether or not the universe is infinite
or finite it's a question we don't know
the answer yet how the universe got its
spots I remember that yeah Hell universe
card spots is about could we tell the
shape and size of the universe by
looking in the hot and cold spots in the
Big Bang and then light left over from
the Big Bang but but the question let's
just take it really theoretically we
absolutely do not know that the universe
is infinite and it may well be that it's
finite the way the earth is finite that
you know we leave New York City we
travel in a straight line is maybe we'd
have to swim a little get on a boat but
you traveled a straight line you're
gonna come back to New York City again
and so it could be that when you can
travel forever I was gonna say it's
infinite in what you can try and where
you can travel infinite in you know you
don't get to an edge right never get to
an edge which is beautiful so exactly
the same thing with the universe you're
not gonna sail off the edge of the earth
right look you know Spanish explorers
waved goodbye and wondered if they'd
just go off the side but no we know
that's not what happens it's so
similarly we could leave the Milky Way
galaxy we could watch it recede behind
us we could travel in a straight a line
as possible and find ourselves coming
back to the Milky Way again you know and
it's it's so planet of the apes right
it's like through my interpretation of
that was that they went all the way
around and so the interesting thing is
that also means that if you look at
distant galaxies the light is also
traveling all the way around the
universe so it could be at some of those
distant galaxies are the Milky Way and
we're seeing the light from the Milky
Way wrap all the way around and come
back to us we'd be seeing the Milky Way
in the past so we it would be hard to
know like maybe we'd see an active black
hole quasar with jets flying out in the
early phases of the Milky Way and we
think oh that's just a different galaxy
Wow yeah so we've galaxies the the young
galaxies look very different from mature
galaxies right and we used to think that
there were different kinds of objects in
the outer universe like boys ours why
they all distant how comes not a quasar
right next door with these monstrous
nuclear emissions and we had to like
figure out that it's it's likely just
younger galaxies and maybe we'd used to
look like a quasar and we don't anymore
right so even a distant galaxy looking
back at us is seeing us in the past
given the light travel time so we could
still look like a quasar to a distant
galaxy like we're I have this huge
active galactic well and then it gets
more because there are reasons that
people start to suspect that there are
extra spatial dimensions and that they
are not only finite but really
technically really small like that
journey to go all the way around them is
something that would would happen
incredibly quickly and it's too small
for us to like literally stick our hands
in that direction in some sense so we're
looking everywhere those extra
dimensions are everywhere but we can't
actually notice them and so a dimension
to be smaller than another dimension but
yeah I mean so think of like
a straw is a good example where it's a
two-dimensional surface drawers were
made of I'm gonna go with flax it's cuz
flaxen hair oh yeah that's connection
between flex and strata there there so
so a straw is small in one direction on
the surface right if you you think
there's a direction in which it's
totally wrapped up and small and then
there's a long direction so straws are
mostly long they're mostly long and you
could glue the top and at the bottom of
a straw to make that long direction also
finite so then you travel around the one
it could be really big
you know mile around but still be
connected but it's only a few
millimeters around in this direction in
this other dimension so literally the
length of traveling before you come back
to where you started it's small so most
of how you use a straw does not access
that other dimension usually the length
you're trying to get the liquid from
here to here yeah of yours you using the
long dimension yeah we done the question
we start to ask is what if the universe
is a kind of space-time origami when
it's created in the Big Bang that all
the dimensions are wrapped up and maybe
in very complicated ways like the
dimension of the straw being wrapped up
but one dimension just gets very very
big or in our case three can be very
very big we have three big dimensions we
have time which is a fourth so we you
know there's up-down
north-south-east-west
that's it you specify those things and
you definitely know where you are in
space you specify time and we can
actually meet right here we are
but those extra directions just maybe
didn't ever expand and so one of the
things even then I'll work on and string
theorists will work on people is why
would only three dimensions get large if
those other dimensions exist interesting
mm-hmm so it could be that will
understand the large connectedness
finite nature space by looking in like
really high energy accelerator
experiments because people have asked at
the Large Hadron Collider could you
perceive these extra dimensions if they
exist okay weeks worth of that is a big
step as a fascinating stuff just
fascinating an extra okay so let's let's
move on to Paul love who says given that
because you can pronounce his name let
me tell you something as a matter of
fact I think I'm just gonna call
everybody Paul love
Paul says this given that our universe
expanded from a single point and is
expanding in all directions how does
that not define the shape of the
universe as spherical how could
something flat or saddle shape come out
of that well it is true if there is an
explosion in space it tends to have a
kind of spherical cloud leftover is
debris so when a star explodes we will
see alpha nebula and they they're like
sphere often spherical fish a beautiful
very beautiful and you know sometimes
they plow into stuff and it changes
shape but basically yeah then you can
point inside this debris point to where
the center of the explosion was so
that's not how it works for the big
thing so for the Big Bang you cannot
imagine that the space exists first and
that you're exploding into the space
right actually a creation of the space
itself right so everywhere right in the
universe was once at the center of the
explosion exactly there is no plowing
out it's as though and you can think of
it any shape you want make some crazy
you know people like the balloon analogy
so now make some crazy balloon twist it
up crazy thing and poodle a poodle and
the whole thing stretches and the whole
thing was once a point so every single
point on that surface that fabric if you
want to call yeah we are as is every
other point in space can I say that
different will you allow me to save
different can I say there is a center
the only way you can access it is to go
back in time to the beginning of time
well you could say okay the center of
all of this only at one coordinate
systems at T equals zero
I would say that's their if time line is
just always there there's the center
yeah if we're gonna be really you know
split space up in very fine-grain terms
this point was at the center back at T
equals zero and this point was at the
center back at T equals zero they just
rolled right so the whole it's just the
collapse of those points at TI zero
yeah gotcha yeah but I like what you
said though which i think is what people
have to really think yes the space
itself was created the second not second
look the millisecond microsecond
whatever nano seconds afterwards
that's that space was created then along
with everything else I think that's like
10 to the minus 43 seconds you know
right then so that I mean that if you
think of it that way because what what
you're thinking about is these distances
between these stuff that we see yeah and
we think they're empty but they came
from actual steam effects Wow go ahead
here's where people get tripped up with
the balloon analogy because it's flawed
as are all analogies is that a lot of
people immediately want to point to the
center of the balloon the empty space
inside but you got to give up on that
all that exists is the skin of the
balloon all that exists okay with the
center of the balloon because that's
where the balloon was at T equals zero
right so you could think of it good I
can only consider the center of the
balloon as snapshots like movie frames
so it once was there and then it was a
movie frame over here that same balloon
is still now at the outer reaches at
that balloon because it came from the
center of the balloon
Oh imagine you painted dots all over the
little infinitesimally small balloon but
if they were glued to do no there's
stains on the skin the balloon there
dots themselves don't move and then you
push all that down so all the dots are
together and then you pull them apart in
some sense those are the galaxies that
came later the galaxies aren't moving
right just stayed on the balloon doesn't
move it's the the skin the stretching
between those spots so in fact nothing
piles up the way it does when a
supernova explodes everything actually
just gets more and more diffuse as a
universe expands wildman all right that
was that was great thanks Paul
all right here we go let's go - Brendan
Rico suave you just girl with me Brendan
okay Brendan wants to know this I've
recently heard of a new study that
states the universe is thought to be in
the shape of a loop whereas previously
it was thought to be flat but in the
explanation given the nature of the loop
shade states that it travels far enough
in one direction that you'll end up back
where you started which is what we
talked about earlier my question is
wouldn't this happen regardless of
actual shapes of the universe so this
point is like no matter what shape and
if would that happen yeah and I think
that you can say I think that we have to
take a break when we come back Janna
Levin is gonna tell us do we live in a
loop universe or not on Startalk
we're back cosmic queries start off
Chuck nice mykos thank you all right
Jenna left friend colleague up it
Barnard in Columbia doing that physics
thing it's got to do it blow people's
cosmological mind so so tell us as the
question had asked do would the universe
loop back on itself no matter its shape
so not necessarily you know what shape
the universe is in the first place yeah
it's really we don't ultimately know the
shape we know that we can see the
distance light has been able to travel
since the Big Bang because we can't see
anything faster than the limit of this
beautiful light travel time and and we
know that the universe is expanding so
that's actually 92 billion light years
across about that week and that's what
we call the observable universe now it's
possible that it's not 92 billion
light-years across that even within that
range that the universe has folded back
onto itself in some way and we're
actually seeing repeats of things we're
starting to see it's kind of like a Hall
of Mirrors thing we're starting to see
the light multiple times how would you
know yeah I was is very very hard to
figure out so there have been extremely
clever ideas and most of them would look
out and I see Chuck waving at me it's
true we're looking at ourselves in the
past which is very hard to distinguish
if for instance if we're looking at
galaxies that's very hard to do but
there are patterns and the hot and cold
spots left over from the Big Bang if it
fits into a specific shape so imagine
something just totally platonically
beautiful and crazy that the universe is
like a dodecahedron all of whose faces
are glued together so it's a crazy
origami that thing is I mean there has
so many loops and yeah that is triangles
right and that is conceivable kind of
what we call topology or connectedness
of the space there it would actually
start to imprint that the the patterns
of the dodecahedron in the light left
over from the Big Bang so if you imagine
there's tiny little hot and cold spots
that you would start to see in the
distribution of the hot and cold spots
that she's that shape would be reflected
in a very subtle way really yes
the reason the udemy reflected literally
you mean manifest manifested so so how
the leopard got its spots is actually a
very similar mathematical problem
because you're asking about enzymes
being higher low in the developing
embryo and it turns out that the shape
and the size of the animal and like
whether it's tubular or when no spots or
hitting it that it will determine what
kind of spots the animal gets its actual
leopard in an actual effort zebra
stripes like these things are things you
can predict by solving for the
mathematics of of things that are above
a certain threshold or below a certain
threshold that that pattern of stripes
or spots will reflect the geometry and
black panther's of leopard you knew that
yes I did know that black heather has
spots now that is this game it's has
spots when it's kids you look very
carefully you can see the spots right
Wow amazing well so so how the universe
got it spots as a similar mathematical
problem we're solving for hot and cold
spots in a particular geometry when the
universe was like a developing embryo
basically and this goes back to Alan
Turing who solved some of these problems
for the animal but like a black panther
does the universe care about injustice
[Laughter]
or does the universe have vibranium you
know we can hope that we're the bad
example and then elsewhere in the
universe there are better examples nice
well well said well said i Chuck what
else yeah all right here we go this is
Tim braid who wants to know this a very
recent study in the Astrophysical
Journal found that galaxies may be
rotating in sync with other galaxies
millions of light years away galaxies
separated by six mega parsecs were found
directly interacting with each other
what is your opinion on this first of
all is that empirical the the fact that
these galaxies were actually interacting
with one another I think that that study
is probably still controversial and
probably still
requires these things can happen but it
just sounds not that likely so there
will be a lot of people doing
observations from different wave bands
with different perspectives to try to
break any possibility that it's a quirk
of this particular yeah observation but
six megaparsecs you know that's pretty
far away yes and and so you would think
that you would be dominated there by the
expansion of the universe and not
interactions we definitely interact with
other galaxies that's not a big surprise
yeah Andromeda Sanjana that's a happy
future like imagine when a German it
gets much closer how cool the night sky
is gonna be it won't be as cool as you
say at the end of your answer is it
coming in edge-on no it's a disturbing
reason why it's not gonna be cool well
now you just I'm sorry because I'm yeah
but all over the place but I gotta get
this in before we move on yeah so
speaking of edge-on so if you're looking
at something agile and how do we flip it
to get the imagery to know that we were
looking at the disc from the edge so we
do that with our own Milky Way we're in
the Milky Way so we're seeing the rest
of the galaxy edge on right we've never
seen the Milky Way as human beings from
above but we have these beautiful
constructions because we just map things
as accurately as we understand where
they are also in space okay so we just
we build an atlas of it basically you
killed them you build a numerical model
based on all of your observations of the
Milky Way the gas the dust the stars
everything where the spirals are where
the gaps are and then you just allow
yourself to move in that digital world
and look down from above but it's an
experiment of making once you have a map
you go anywhere you want
three-dimensional map you go anywhere
yeah plus we see all the gas and we're
quite a flattened in the sky and there
are other galaxies out there that are
flattened and we can see them at all not
one galaxy of different angles but a
million galaxies all scattered in random
angles so it's pretty easy to figure out
what we look like we look like until we
collide with Andromeda but one of the
things I took solace in but I feel like
Neil's about sorry but the whole solar
system supposed to stay together right
and get knocked around we should stay
together so we might end up in Andromeda
before we fully acquired like they could
pass each other they could collide move
through each other and we could end up
in Andromeda looking at the Milky Way
we're gonna leave a forwarding address
so what will happen is there'll be a lot
of sort of dissipated energy and the
system will of course pass through each
other and back and forth we've done this
on a computer and it's like a rubber
band kind of thing and it kind of dies
down and it settles into one double
large massive system okay so what's a
bad news okay so that sounds like good
news yeah
so if Andromeda were a hundred times
closer
it wouldn't be any brighter on the sky
hmm interesting yeah okay I'm Lively
okay yeah tell me what it's not obvious
okay okay okay all right so Andromeda
has a certain size on the sky
correct okay it has a certain extent
mm-hmm and on a very dark night mm-hmm
not in the city but where this moon is
not out you can see this fuzzy thing in
the sky so that's in the Andromeda
galaxy it's two million light years away
all right there's a certain amount of
light coming from Andromeda in that
patch on the sky right so we we
reference it's something called a
surface brightness it is how bright is
Andromeda over that patch of sky over
that surface patch on the sky surface
brightness okay if we bring it half as
far away okay they make it only half as
far it is how many times brighter it's
got like the square square but then the
enemies four times brighter
by a factor of four yeah so so so the
whole system is getting brighter but the
surface area is remaining the same so it
is not going to be more apparent to you
in the night sky that our own Milky Way
is on our own night sky I'm very sad to
report that no it'll just still be fuzzy
can I see it
gotta get out of the city moon now I see
the colliding galaxies no sorry I'm very
sorry about this that's right I'm you
know it'll just look like our own Milky
Way galaxy drummer right here next to it
just look like our Milky Way yeah it's
guy I cannot see from you but you can
see with one of those apps like you can
just and it could be like down there and
it'll show you like a Andromeda on its
way and you pump up the count the day
the intensity needs eyes we're
practically blind this is the moon
bottom for astronomy yeah she is so
right on this Chuck yeah Chuck we call
glasses as the as the centuries went on
we discovered how blind we actually were
yeah that's amazing
yeah all right there we go okay let's
move on to David oh by the way those
Hubble photos yes if you go to those
objects you don't see what the Hubble
saw because the Hubble sees better than
you do a lot I mean if your eyeballs
were like like god Dan target you would
then it'll look like what the Hubble
seen right all right cool all right this
is David Eduardo Morales Martinez who
wants good there yeah well not bad you
know my wife is Puerto Rican
here again Joe David or what would be
David Eduardo Perales Martinez Martinez
yes who says this why is it so hard to
prove the existence of other dimensions
thank you
David from Mexico oh yeah Mexico asked
that a slightly different way yeah if
there was another dimension as big as
the three that were in would completely
manifest to us probably there's a hitch
so you would think yes as long as that
dimension was very large then we would
be talking about a world in which this
did not confine us right so let's say I
have skin which seems to separate my
inside of my outside but right inside
you if right if there was another
dimension you could do like one of those
Spooky's surgeries without your
puncturing any skin you could just like
go in there and touch people's organs
like this would not be a separation of
inside and outside analogy to that is if
you're only live in two dimensions then
you only have sort of heightened with
heightened you have height and width but
not depth so if you don't have depth
when I if I look at you in two
dimensions I can see all your organs for
you whatever you can't see because
you're in the end all you see is the
outer skin which is it's a line which is
just a line yeah and now our outer skin
is a surface right right so which is why
you know you can't actually probably
have a very effective organism in just
two dimensions because let's say they
had a mouth and a tube going all the way
through them it would actually cut the
two sides in half yeah so you can't have
what we consider be normal metabolic
functions of okay anything else you
don't have you don't have porosity in
two dimensions yeah they tell me yes oh
so if you drop water on soil and then it
just soaks in right or you drop it on a
sponge and it soaks in okay in two
dimensions there's no such thing as
there's no silky there's no snow soaking
in right so you just have a bulb of
water elbow of water correcting on top
of porosity enables you have to let's
say two rocks or touching here mm-hmm
but then the water can just go around
another side of the rock right but in
two dimensions where they touch there is
no way past it right just stay above it
is that where you're able to smell what
The Rock is cooking okay some people
argue that the reason why the universe
is three-dimensional is because the
universe tries to be many different ways
there may have been an infinite number
of big bangs in the past in the future
can really talk about it in temporal
relative nough stood amenity large
universe with all the rest rolled up and
small you couldn't have organisms in
that universe to ask the questions Wow
you'd need at least three and then let's
say you had four spatial dimensions then
you have the problem of things drift
away from each other in such a way that
it's hard to have organized systems so
just like Neil is describing a
two-dimensional creature isn't aware of
the third dimension but if they became
aware they could just kind of float away
from their city right it becomes you
have more volume of space to fill mm-hmm
the cross-section for interaction goes
down so now if you add another dimension
the cross-section for interaction goes
down again no but we successfully exists
in three dimensions in spite of the
challenges the two-dimensional creature
would face upon accessing a third
dimension right so why maybe three
optimal why don't four dimensional
creatures pity us Yeah right well that's
that I mean that is a good question
could the complexity like I'm just I'm
not saying they're true arguments but
some people argue that you couldn't in
the four dimensions get the successful
complexity and some of those arguments
are they get you know complicated based
on string theory cross sections and
annihilations into photons and what's
left over after all of these things in
the Big Bang it turns out that Tony only
a tiny tiny bit of stable matter is left
over already in three dimensions what
could be wait a minute let me kind of
agree with what you just said even
though I just agreed yeah what you're
saying is in three dimensions it could
be optimal for particles to get together
and make molecules and molecules to make
macroscopic objects if you add a fourth
dimension
you're adding a degree of freedom of
where things can hang out and possibly
never then find each other yeah wait if
you think about the volume of the
universe is going up radically with the
volume of dimensions yes then you're
diluting everything and the inspiration
of what could be so the fact that you're
even asking that question means you are
a being in an optimized universe to even
pose the question in the first place
so the two-dimensional people couldn't
ask this question right because they
couldn't be 2-dimensional people because
the structures are too simple to allow
and four dimensional people there's too
much play space so let's take it let's
take you your first question was would
we know it if the other dimensions were
large here's the hitch you would think
we would but here's a hitch
even if all of those problems were
solvable there is an argument that we
could be glued to a kind of a membrane
which is a three dimensional surface
floating in this higher dimensional
space it's the way the fundamental
forces work between the keepers they
keep us on the membrane and the only
thing that happily goes off the membrane
is is gravity itself so that all other
forces are glued to this membrane that's
where they live so that you would think
like a particle to you interacting with
that membrane could be a string in the
higher dimensional space passing through
your space as a particle manifesting as
a particle so I can Majan cutting a
string you would it would look to you
like a dot right an infinitely thin
string so I'll think about in two
dimensions I think of passing a a hollow
sphere through two dimensions what would
that look like to the two-dimensional
people they'd see a dot they say well
that's cool right
oh then it becomes like a circle and it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger then
it maximizes out at the diameter but
they don't know this and then it gets
smaller then it gives a point and
disappears and they have no idea
no in spherical mystical manacles
hypotheses come out yes and the
scientists to analyze it would you say
stuff pops in and out of existence we
don't know
so what one of the yeah absolutely so
one of the things that we've worked on
with extra dimensions that make them not
just an oddity but maybe something we've
already observed one of the things we've
worked on on our extra dimension
superhero nemesis character in the
making my superhero character name is
Jan 11 isn't it good and it's a prime
number Jan I mean I've got a work that
you don't want to be the Nemesis so the
interesting thing there that where
people have thought about is that maybe
something like dark energy is actually a
quantum phenomenon trapped in the extra
dimensions that we can't perceive the
extra dimensions directly but we're
indirectly perceiving them through the
dark or dark matter is regular matter in
the higher dimensions leaking over and -
right and which is this membrane we just
turn this and it's just mysteriously
there yeah we people have definitely one
that is the medium is that the gravity
is space-time so gravity can't be
confined got to otherwise that would be
no meaning to the extra dimension stupid
[Laughter]
take a quick break okay when we come
back more with Jan 11 on the edge of the
universe and beyond in star talk returns
we're back start off cosmic queries the
edge of the universe there's only one
person in arms reach out there that who
could do this generally Janet these are
go to the person yes totally do I have
actually written papers on extra
dimensions it is a genuine direction in
my mind in them in my research is to
think so what she disappears just be so
just like caught up and then like went
into the fourth dimension this is yeah
Monsters Inc yeah the doors yeah that
came out of the factory right this was
an uncelebrated fact of that movie these
are four dimensional portals that
basically wormholes h door this is the
door to the kids room and the monster
takes it home at the end of the day and
they open the door and the other side of
the door is the kid's closet right okay
okay and then they come out the closet
scare the kid go back through the door
and they're back at home it is a great
movie let's let's go to well you know
what let's go back to a patreon patron
this is uh solar Cyril
dare I okay who says what do y'all think
what do y'all think about the idea that
matter consumed by black holes has been
recycled and manifested back into the
universe as dark energy so matter coming
out the other side maybe right okay is
there any correlation between the matter
consumed by black holes and dark energy
black holes and dark energy dark matter
be different sides of the same coin
I mean where to begin with this saying
there's an urge to take everything you
don't know and assume it's related right
so I've got people talking about dark
matter
consciousness God yeah and dark energy
or as one thing right quantum quantum
spookiness yes someone asked me when
they take ayahuasca is it possible that
they have gone to a higher
okay okay my answer to in an attempt to
not be totally dismissive was to say
well if it's a platonic form that we can
learn about by exploring the mind then
in that sense maybe right right like a
perfect circle doesn't exist in reality
nor will a perfect circle ever exist
anywhere in the universe but you can
touch it in your mind right and it's an
experiment we can all perform so that in
that sense we go places unlocking
secrets in the minds the physical
universe itself yes yes about dark
matter dark energy so let's just with
the falling and coming out and so there
there were very early on people who
thought a black hole could be bigger on
the inside than the outside it could be
as big as an entire universe on the
inside it could actually lead to a white
hole which is basically a Big Bang so so
you fall into the black hole and you
know that is completely confined by the
event horizon nothing ever comes out but
inside it is like something as big as an
entire universe right another universe
right
exactly it's just like doctor who's
TARDIS and and so we would never know
about that universe it would not connect
us check-check
street-cred TARDIS is an acronym for
what
oh no relative dimension in space
relative dimension in space it doesn't
make it into the acronym I'm just gonna
say you know okay so so so that was an
interesting idea and a lot of people
object to it because it in some subtle
way suggests an unstable 'no stew
BIGBANG's that might make it so that
this world couldn't be stable if that
with you but honestly it's not
completely off the table there's a lot
you could talk to some very important
early relativists able still say that's
what happens relativist an expert on
relativity and relativity so then
there's a separate totally separate
question about dark
there is a suggestion that the black
hole's themselves could be dark matter
meaning that they are invisible like
dark matter is technically and and they
could populate the universe almost
arguably large enough to explain this
missing mass this missing matter it's on
the edge it's definitely under pressure
right but there's a problem with like
Big Bang nucleosynthesis if it's
ordinary matter mm-hmm the black hole's
don't have to be made by collapsing
stars out of ordinary matter but you're
absolutely right we don't know how to
make enough narrations right so they're
not made from stars so it can
potentially my black hole let's do it I
want to know what's inside the lunch box
okay and inside of it is a black hole
thermos but of course it is confusing if
you fall into a black hole like this I
guess you can't see your hands oh yeah
yeah you'll disappear in front of
yourself okay so you have a black hole
thermos and it is filled with okay so
liquor this is an inversion of the known
universe because in this particular case
inside your black hole I have the Milky
Way outside the black hole because the
black hole is always inside the Milky
Way I am just gonna say that that was
the most committed joke I have ever seen
in my life those of you who don't have a
camera I'm just telling you Neil had an
actual Milky Way candy bar inside of a
black hole thermos okay that's black
hole lunch box okay so the last question
which is pretty hard is could they all
be connected the stuff that falls in and
comes out and classically would say no
way that horizon separates everything
with me inside the outside but then
there's
quantum entanglement visor maybe some
particles on the inside are also the
same thing as the particles on the
outside they're the same particles
because of entanglement and wormholes
and some crazy stuff at nobody really
it's all just very conjectural now but
maybe we'll come back in 20 years we'll
be open for it yeah as a follow-up to
this cosmic queries 20 years from now
yes people roll us in wheelchairs so we
got a round here Chuck yeah we so Jan
you're gonna answer these sound bites
okay amped this is bunters 85 on
instagram and wants to know this I know
it's off topic but one of your last
shows you were talking about the
information on the surface of a black
hole what do you mean by information D
mean temperature or speed or what is
information ultimately we are completely
definable in terms of our quantum
numbers just list of facts about us
information about us and relative
locations and organisms in my body take
let's take a single fundamental particle
in your body it has mass charge spin and
it's identical to every let's call it an
electron in this case every other
electron identical one's not a little
bit heavier one's a little bit lighter
and we're completely definable in terms
of that information and you cannot
destroy that information interesting and
so so in quantum mechanics you start to
stop thinking and if I melt Chuck yeah
technically
all of that information is still in the
universe right just arrange two strands
oh my god that's sensible there's a
puddle on the ground yeah that's a
different Chuck from the chuck I'm
talking to right now how's that
information still there yes it will
never change
having information preserved doesn't
mean there can't be local change right
so I can definitely change things
locally but I still have to have the
same information trying to total system
the total system so I have to be able to
reconstruct something it doesn't mean
that there's a change in the system with
what's in the system
have to necessarily be able to
reconstruct the exact same thing
information right in principle I should
be able to if I took a page of the
encyclopedia and burnt it I should be
able to reconstruct it in principle of
course nobody can ever really do that it
would take longer than the age of the
universe and we don't have that kind of
computing power so there's physical
impossibilities but ignoring those
complications black hole the argument is
that what actually might be happening is
that the information as it's falling in
which is basically all you know
everything everything right never
actually makes it inside the black hole
it becomes encoded on the boundary which
is you meant horizon so it's actually a
hologram elías 82 from Instagram says
NASA reported that Voyager 2 discovered
two new details about interstellar space
how does that change our understanding
of dark energy beyond our solar system
or does it it probably doesn't because
it isn't a detector of dark energy or
dark matter we have no detectors of dark
energy or dark matter yet none
successful and so what but it is amazing
that is the first human-made object
that's gone interstellar and that really
is quite spectacular it's just broken
out of basically the sun's magnetic
influence so it's able to get cosmic
rays and things that that are protected
in the solar system by the sun's may
need to think the solar system was how
far out of the planets and then you have
like the Kuiper belt comets then you
have the more cloud then you say well
really at what distance does an object
no longer know that the Sun is in this
direction right because the Sun has
magnetic influences that go very far and
you reach the point where all the field
measurements are sort of in this soup
that permeates the entire galaxy and so
it's a transition from the Sun is this
way - I got stars in every direction
right and so still moving so slowly that
it will take what ten thousand years to
reach another no 70,000 70,000 yes
Robert
who says thanks so much for educating
and inspiring us what news in science do
you find most interesting and important
right now with respect to your field wow
that's a great question
well we do live the soundbite yeah we
are in a very lucky time because we have
discovered bear black holes in this
miraculous way so I do think that the
most exciting is yeah is eating meals
Milky Way so I do think it is where the
small meets the large and it will be
that way for a long time meaning what
the big bang tells us about dark matter
and dark energy and the universe on the
larger scale and why those things are
folded together thinking about the the
universe on the biggest scale and on the
small scale so where quantum physics
meets general relativity fresh air is an
unresolved territory that's right and so
that's why we use all these real
settings right if you want to if you
want to understand what quantum
mechanics meets gravity you got to do it
in the Big Bang around black holes all
right this is Pablo Grist insko I don't
know Pablo I'm sorry can you please help
me put inside my head one more dimension
three is fine
but how can I grasp more that's a what
do you do with what do you do with
people to let them understand I think it
is absolutely imperative that everyone
understands that nobody can just
blanketly visualize higher dimensions
we're accustomed to looking at
dimensions from the outside looking down
we can't do that so what we can do with
the kinds of things that Neil is
describing earlier which is imagine
three dimensional cross-sections of
things so visualizing a hyper sphere
which is a higher dimensional sphere as
an intersection of it with our three
dimensions and it would be a series of
console it would be a series of spheres
right that would max out and then
spheres would go back but the one last
thing is to do the to do the difficult
example of being a flatlander and you
will actually just by going down and
dimension to get it yeah and I can add
that if I've said this in a couple of
our talks before there's another moment
to do so if a line is bounded by points
mm-hmm and a square is bounded by lines
and a cube is bounded by squares then a
hypercube is bounded by
three-dimensional cubes the sides of a
hypercube are three-dimensional cubes
right mathematically just work your way
up just keep going on we'll take you
there there that's their math set you
free think you know this is a real
example where the math makes it a lot
easier okay they just said no one ever
math to make it easier geometry okay
this is uh Eric Spence and Mark Eric
Benson he says this Neil you have said
before the Dark Matter should really be
called dark gravity and it really stuck
with me and helped me understand it
better
do you have a similar and alternate name
for dark energy that better summarizes
the phenomenon I'll give it a shot but I
want to hear it let's see what Janus
Edison's yeah I would say I would just
call it dark expansion stuff but
definitely dark gravity is what dark
matter is it is literally dark gravity
and I'm totally cool with that
are you totally cool with that totally
cool is a neutrino dark gravity oh
that's a form of dark matter like we
have examples of forms of dark matter
that we have detected they're just not
plentiful enough to explain so much of
it yeah but there are things called
neutrinos which we do detect and they
are dark meaning they don't interact
with light that was rough man
with the dark energy that what if we
thought of it it's like an invisible
ocean because that's sort of what the
dark energies around us all the time and
it's it's as though we're in a storm of
dark particles and it's just it's really
that it's invisible is the thing you can
see right through it it's not that if
you had it in your hands it would look
dark it's Jim visible right right so
yeah so both dark and energy really
don't apply
we need yeah okay you know so it's
really in the vacuum vacuum bad okay
okay okay half a sound bite this is
Hector Salazar who says this can other
universes influence our overlap with our
own and is there any evidence that this
might be happened this would be the
parallel universe yeah very speculative
but if you consider a universe let's say
we're floating on a three-dimensional
membrane and a higher dimensional space
and there's another one of those
floating also in the higher dimensional
space parallel or in some sense anyway
they both share this membrane you're
talking about that sense would call them
universes and yes it is possible that
they have interacted in the past and
that there would be some archaeological
record of that or in the future if they
intersect is there an intersection line
the three-dimensional line in which you
live in both universes so technically if
you mean by universe the galaxies and
everything you see and not the whole
space-time then technically yes two
universes two membranes can can interact
and can can coexist yeah I like the idea
of living on the boundary between two
universes people many other universes
aren't a-holes as long as the laws of
physics there are the same name as ours
because you don't want to decompose into
a pile of goo yeah that would be bad
that would be bad the charge of electron
is different
we gotta call it quits they're always
good to have you on so much fun
Jan 11 / physics up at Columbia and
Barnard College I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist signing off
first our talk bidding you as always
[Music]